it's hard to imagine a more
quintessentially american vehicle than
the pickup truck
[Music]
but this age-old love affair is about to
get a shock that could change that
relationship forever
[Music]
outside of north america trucks with
open pickup beds are generally
considered utility vehicles for
commercial use and don't sell in
particularly high volume
but in the us they're practically a
cultural institution when you drive
america's truck there's one place you'll
want to be
pickup trucks have been kind of the
centerpiece for much of the u.s auto
market for 60 or 70 years really
certainly since world war ii if not
earlier they represent the highest
volume vehicles in the u.s and they
represent the highest profit vehicles in
the u.s
had one since i was in my 20s couldn't
function doing what i'm doing with that
one this is probably my fourth or fifth
truck i've had this same model of truck
since i was 17 and i'm now 52. for work
this one fits my purposes perfectly
the numbers are staggering nearly one in
five vehicles sold in the us are pickup
trucks and in april 2020 for the first
time ever pickup trucks outsold
passenger cars which have been on a
steady decline for years
with reliable sales and healthy profit
margins you would expect manufacturers
to not mess with a proven formula
because the manufacturers have this big
question that they're always fighting
with how many of our resources do we
apply to our current business models
that make money for us right now and how
much of our resources do we allot for
longer term future investment the
interest in electric trucks has been
building for a while in the background
but as we all know when elon musk makes
a splash everyone kind of watches
[Music]
tesla essentially threw the first pitch
in a game that few people outside of the
auto industry even knew was being played
and as of mid-2020 no fewer than seven
models by seven different manufacturers
are currently in development supported
by an astounding amount of marketing
hype for a category that has yet to
deliver a single vehicle to market
seeing the world not as it is but how it
could be that is how you change the
world
what makes this race especially exciting
is that it isn't just a battle between
the major well-heeled industry players
but also a lineup of young companies
that resemble silicon valley startups
complete with flashy names and
headline-grabbing ceos
tesla has proven that it's possible to
come out of nowhere as an automaker and
become a real player and a real force in
the industry and i think every one of
them is hoping to be the tesla of trucks
including tesla
i think a lot of these startups are
feeling like we don't need to steal
fifty percent of the f-150s market share
if we can steal
four percent of the f-150s market share
we're gonna sell a lot of trucks
while early adopters may be enticed by
new tech or environmental impact the
electric pickup's fate will come down to
convincing loyal customers that it's
demonstrably better for the same or less
cost and that's where the innovation
race comes in
saw that a model t got 24 miles per
gallon the average car still gets about
24 miles per gallon right physics of
that recipe of pistons going up and down
and routing power
it you can't get past so
the only way to have a quantum leap is
to reinvent it
typical fraternal combustion engine
vehicle will have north of 2000 moving
parts every moving part is a loss of
efficiency
that's what's really different about our
pickup truck it only has four moving
parts the wheels
there is nothing simpler than a motor in
each wheel and a computer watching that
that motor very precisely
after 95 years pickup trucks get about
15 miles per gallon we've invented a
pickup truck that gets equivalent of 75
miles per gallon five-fold is efficient
comparing gas to electric one of the
first things that you notice immediately
is the delivery of torque and how much
torque there is in an electric vehicle
there's zero lag so as soon as you step
on the throttle you're getting instant
torque
and that's great for the type of
usability that you wanted to pick up
when you're rock crawling or off-roading
or even just normal driving situations
it gives you a lot of confidence and
it's really enjoyable to drive every
night when you go home you can plug it
in just like you plug in your phone and
it's ready to go the next day fully
charged ready to roll
but still floating around are concerns
that have been part of the ev debate all
along particularly around range anxiety
with electric trucks range can vary
widely on the carrying or towing load
reducing it by up to 50 in some cases at
the notion of freedom that is heavily
baked into american truck marketing is
limited by rapid charging infrastructure
which is still far from widespread
especially in rural areas where pickup
trucks are common
and then there's another factor you
personally would you be able to switch
to an electric truck uh
hard to say
it kind of all depends on how expensive
they are
i would if it was cost effective
so how much do these trucks cost well
according to what's been announced so
far there's a pretty wide range from
around forty thousand dollars in the low
end to well over a hundred thousand
dollars
and different models are clearly
targeted toward different types of
customers nonetheless that range begins
well above the cheapest gas powered
pickups on the market even when taking
into account the current various federal
and state level credits for electric
vehicles
the good news though is that the core
technology behind this segment batteries
continue to get cheaper since 2010
battery prices have fallen 87 that's
lithium ion battery pack prices from
2010 to 2019. that's a really really
sharp drop and that's starting to get
you to the point where automakers can
make and sell an ev for a reasonable
profit margin for most automakers it's
still lower than the margins they make
on their average internal combustion
engine vehicles
but it's certainly getting closer as we
saw with tesla model s start at the high
end and kind of work your way down i
think you'll see something a bit similar
with pickups is that some of these that
come out are going to be targeted a
little at the higher end for the first
few years until those costs come down a
little bit further
what's fascinating about trucks is that
in many ways they are perfect candidates
for electric electric drivetrains
they're larger they have more space for
the battery packs you can hide or
integrate the additional cost of the ev
components into its price easier than
you can say a compact car i think that
all will help trucks potentially succeed
if you can get the end user to go for
them one thing the companies are
succeeding at already is setting
expectations high such as gm claiming a
three second zero to sixty time for its
thousand plus horsepower hummer ev or
nikola offering a 600 mile estimated
maximum range on its hydrogen cell
fuel-equipped badger
but delivering on the promises of these
prototypes in a mass production vehicle
is a whole other challenge especially
for the startups
they don't have to just make trucks
they've got to get a supply chain going
distribution system assembly plants
everything so it's relatively easy to
produce a single or even a couple
concept vehicles that look really neat
building high volume electric trucks at
a high quality and distributing them
throughout the country or throughout the
world is a much bigger undertaking long
term
they're either going to need a lot more
money or they're going to need to align
with a traditional automaker some of the
startups have already embraced the
cliche if you can't beat them join them
usually in the form of a healthy
contribution to their balance sheet
michigan-based rivian counts forward
among its family of investors with the
legendary f-150 maker committing half a
billion dollars so far
meanwhile business fleet focused
lordstown motors has made its
relationship with a legacy brand a
little more physical gm was closing a
plant here in lordstown ohio it made
chevy cruises
and uh we were able to purchase a plant
but most importantly intact so two
thousand robots four stamping presses
full paint booth body shop you know
everything
there's a huge workforce around here
it's great generations of automotive
bankers and we're going to be here for a
long time because this is the future
in addition to taking over a former gm
plant lordstown recently announced that
it would be going public in a deal that
would net almost 700 million dollars to
fund operations and one of its principal
supporters you've probably guessed it
general motors
the next few years are going to be
particularly interesting to watch as the
entangling industry alliances shake out
while the different models make it to
market hopefully
but there's more than just corporate
profit riding on the promise of the
electric pickup its success could be a
major inflection point in the american
adoption of electric vehicles
historically there's been this
incredible mismatch between
what consumers are buying in north
america which is more and more trucks
and suvs and with the segments that a
lot of those evs that we saw over the
last 10 years launched into which were
sedans and often compact sedans at that
so once there's compelling pickup truck
options i think they're they're going to
sell well i'm actually pretty optimistic
that that could change the game a little
bit in the us in terms of ev adoption
over the next five years
of all the pickups on the market today
one is leaving the others behind it's
really a cool thing to disrupt something
that hasn't changed essentially in 95
years
i think all pickup trucks are going to
go electric
there is no reason for them not to
disruption doesn't usually happen
overnight but rather in fits and starts
and eventually an idea that was once
esoteric or whimsical or maybe even
ridiculed becomes simply another
reasonable option and then one day you
wake up and it's the default
i think that's what's going to be
fascinating about the personal
transportation space over the next 10 15
years we are not going to see any one
dominant form of powering a power system
for these vehicles we're going to see an
increased diversity in them and i've
always said there isn't the silver
bullet that's going to solve all our
problems there's a bunch of copper
bullets that add up to a silver bullet
[Music]
you